the problem is the shortage of colleges
in Africa in the developing countries
the mortality rate of calculon vascular
disease is very high so in each family
you will have at least one person who
will suffer from cardiovascular disease
my name is Arthur Zhang I am a computer
science engineer I am the inventor of
the cardio part which is a medical
tablet for heart examination in Cameroon
we have about sixty cartilages for about
22 million inhabitants almost all these
casualties only work in the big city I
grew myself in a small village located
25 kilometres from the capital so I know
how we can be hard to live very far from
the city
I got the idea to develop a software
that can make the heart examination and
also transfer the data from one point to
another in order to help people who live
in village firstly the car apart is a
medical device used to perform heart
examination that means it will perform a
standard 12 lead ECG exam that will help
to record the data of the heart of the
patient and you can then connect to a
remote server to transfer the data what
makes the travel partner is special is
also that it is a mobile machine you can
just make an examination inside a car
inside a home or a very remote village
hospital
[Music]
I'm very proud of the title part because
when we started this project it was very
small we have continued to improve the
software to improve the hardware and now
we see the complete device that has a
very big potential in the future we hope
that we'll have the ability to scale the
project so many people can benefit
wherever in the world
[Music]